county school district has revealed its  proposal to try and get students back  into the classroom  in plans made public yesterday students  would have a mix of  in-person and distance learning  classrooms would only be half  full and students would be divided into  different groups for either hybrid  learning  or full-time distance education mask  wearing and extra sanitation measures  would also be required  trustees will review this plan on  thursday night  clark county's largest teachers union  though opposes the district's plans  in a statement the ccea says it's not  going to back  any reopening without a robust safety  system in place  the union wants testing contact tracing  personal protective equipment  and teachers to have the ability to work  from home if they choose